wednesday is that kind of look back look
forward what do we really do well one
thing we do on wednesdays is give chris
sims a chance to
make me the mayor of crazyville for my
assessment of the 32 teams ranked one
after i do it every tuesday morning try
to get it posted right around the noon
hour so you can sit there and and curse
and swear while you're eating your lunch
while you see where your team is your
team's never as high as you think it
should be chris so today let's unveil
although they were unveiled at pft but
they haven't been officially unveiled
here on pft live the top ten
for week two in the national football
league and to no surprise in new england
patriots after that 33-3 victory over
the steelers still the top team in the
nfl followed by the chiefs who won 40-26
in jacksonville eagles holding firm at
number three after getting a scare from
washington cowboys at four they smashed
the giants 35-17
rams move up to five they had been
number seven seahawks are at number six
holding firm they got leap frog by the
rams which makes sense rams had a more
impressive day i think than seattle
saints up to number seven from eight
vikings up to eight from 11 packers up
seven spots from 16 to nine who says i
don't like aaron rodgers and the
chargers hold firm at number 10. what do
you shut up what do you think what do
you think of those well okay let's start
at the top five i'm just curious because
i just think it's a close one first off
uh did you think about putting the eagle
i mean the eagles and cowboys and
switching that around making the cowboys
three eagles four with just the way the
games looked on sunday
i gave it
a little bit of thought but i figured
you know i still think the eagles are a
better team hey the cowboys smashed the
giants that's fine but uh you could
argue it's even more impressive to show
the the fortitude necessary to dig out
of a 17 nothing hole and come back and
outscore them 32-3
until that that late back end cover
touchdown that washington scored so i
left it three and four i i really didn't
even consider it all that much at all
because i do think the eagles are a half
click above the cowboy yeah i mean i
think generally i do that's a really
close one but man did that cowboys mike
i watched that offense on film yesterday
and you know kellen moore
he's he's earning his paycheck mike it
was a different look from that offense
all together so i'm happy about that
that was a close one to me i would have
looked at that and got ooh
just because it's so close between the
two teams and the way the cowboys looked
i might have gave him the edge what
about the rams at five did you flirt at
all with putting them in front of the
eagles of the cowboys after their
impressive road win in carolina
no i didn't want to jump them up too far
and and i i think that you know jared
goff didn't have a big day and and i
think the panthers had a few yeah
mistakes that contributed to that i i i
think the red this is one of those games
where
the rams you know we saw how sean mcvay
jumped off the podium and said man it
feels good to win that one yeah they
could have lost that one it always feels
good to win a game where
as it's unfolding you have a very strong
sense that it's not going to go your way
and at the end of the day it's like
somehow we won this thing so i didn't
think it was it got him two spots higher
than they were right but it's not going
to get him any higher than that for now
yep okay and then i all right next one
down seahawks not impressive at you know
at home against cincinnati really we're
very fortunate to get out with the win
another game i watched on film yesterday
bangle should have won the game uh i'm
shocked that you put the seahawks or
kept them in front of the saints i
thought maybe you'd have the saints in
front of the seahawks as far as just
talking about your top ten here
and you know i always look for the next
match up and if i can get two teams
right next to each other i'll i'll
push it that way and maybe in hindsight
it should have pushed the saints all the
way to number six because then it would
be five versus six this weekend in the
rematch of the nfc championship so you
know what if i if i had a mulligan yeah
i would probably flip the saints and the
seahawks okay i i i can take
constructive that's i'm amazed as long
as i let's end the segment show's over
see you guys tomorrow listen to this
okay so now i just want to dance down a
little farther okay and i see you don't
push your luck you got the vikings at
eight and the packers at nine but stats
are are
girls and guys in the back and we put up
his 10 through 20 part of his power
rankings because you got the vikings and
packers at eight and nine i'm shocked
you got them in front of the ravens uh
as the way the ravens looked and i
understand it was the dolphins but you
know the vikings packers games you know
they played well but i'm not going to
sit here and just go i was absolutely
blown away with their performances like
i was with the ravens i think the
packers holding the defending nfc north
champions to three points on opening
night of the season in their own
building is more impressive than what
the ravens did because as as we know the
dolphins weren't trying to stop the
ravens i mean
tank no tank whatever they didn't adjust
their defense they continued to dare i
it's like going up to a bully and saying
i dare you to punch me in the face and
he does and you come right back and say
i dare you to punch me in the face
and he does yes they kept doing that to
the ravens offense so i i
who did the ravens beat so they're gonna
have to beat a team that that is better
than the dolphins who
uh would be lower than 32 if that was
possible right they're gonna have to do
something more impressive than that
before they crack the top ten well they
play the cardinals this week so it
doesn't look like they're gonna be
rising that far if they win that game
which i expect them to do but okay i got
no issue that that was a good
explanation overall
i mean i like that and then you're when
i look at your 11 through 20 you know
titans at 12. okay you got a bunch of
teams that lost the brown the bears the
steelers the colts the browns the
jaguars the bills at 1-0 at 18. uh i
guess i'm surprised i thought maybe you
dropped down the browns a little bit
more i thought with the way they looked
the fact that they got blown out at home
when i looked at your power rankings
this morning i thought oh i wonder where
i'll have cleveland it was the first one
i watched and i thought you were going
to have them maybe somewhere
19 20 21 something like that so 16 says
you still are giving hope to that
football team and there's a few things
that scare you or you like about them in
general
well i expected them to lose to the
titans and i think the game got out of
hand in the fourth quarter because as
peter king said yesterday baker mayfield
gets compared to brett favre all the
time and brett favre in those moments
where the game is slipping away will
take chances that he shouldn't take or
wouldn't otherwise take that's what
mayfield did and that's what opened the
floodgates it was not a 30-point victory
if you pay close attention to the game
right it just got out of hand late and
with
7.7.7 points before you know it it does
become a blowout so i think that the
browns hey they still dropped four spots
they get a chance to justify middle of
the pack status and begin their climb
they get
with jets and rams and 49ers and
seahawks and you know it's it's going to
be a tough road for them they're going
to have to earn their way back up toward
the top 10. okay and then how do you
view 18 you got the bills that want to
know behind a bunch of teams that are
all in one and i i understand that
i'm just curious in this in general
because we haven't talked about this
game a lot so far this week how did you
view the bills win and and the mike
florio brain there what what was your
thoughts or synopsis on that that
victory
if the jets had a kicker they would have
won the game that's how i view it yeah
you know so it's hard it's hard to move
the bills all that far up from 20 when
they beat a team that put its faith in a
guy who who had proven why he didn't
belong in the nfl i mean what a scam the
ravens pulled by getting a fifth round
pick for kari vedvic and i applaud the
vikings for not blindly sticking with
vedrick simply because they gave up the
fifth round pick hey chris think about
this one
if vedvic was the vikings kicker on
sunday against the falcons and he missed
the first couple of extra points and
it's 12 nothing instead of 14 nothing i
mean that's just it's a psychological
difference right sure and maybe it's if
it's eight let's say he missed all four
extra points and it was 24 nothing when
the falcons scored that first touchdown
and they they stupidly went for two they
would have reason to go for two right
make it 24-8 then all of a sudden you
got to worry a little bit so having a
kicker who can get it done is worth
something as the saints found out and i
think if the jets hadn't claimed karyvik
on waivers and gave him the job and of
course he lost the job on tuesday as he
should have they uh they would have won
that game so it's it's hard to really
applaud the bills a lot of turnovers
four turnovers they escaped they
shouldn't have and they're not going to
get so lucky when they play better team
no but i still think it's a big thing
for them that they overcame the deficit
they did for a team that's still kind of
young learning a quarterback who
was way too gunslinger in the first half
and you know i like josh allen but he
kind of uh fixed it all up and dialed it
back in in the second half and made some
unbelievable plays the bills are still a
very intriguing football team to maybe
there because you see
that defense is the real deal the the
jets had a hard time moving the ball and
if their offense can play complimentary
football and josh allen play a little
smart smarter i do think the bills are
one of those teams is going to be a pain
in the butt for everybody in the afc
this year
let's look at the last five i've got the
dolphins at 32. there's a shock giants
at 31 after getting beat by 18 by the
cowboys they dropped a spot washington
from 27 down to 30 between blowing the
lead and also the mishandling of adrian
peterson dysfunctional teams do
dysfunctional things and the redskins
are back down in that bottom layer of
dysfunction in the nfl buccaneers at 29
they blew that game at home
against the 49ers by 14. and then the
cardinals you know they they bumped up
from 31 to 28 by pulling out the tie if
they don't won that game who knows how
high they'd be but there's reason for
hope in arizona the way that they isn't
it amazing the way that they were able
to hold it together it speaks to their
conditioning kyler murray said that the
lions got tired late in the game well
the cardinals didn't so regardless of
whatever we think about the offense
whether or not cliff kingsbury has any
business being an nfl head coach in the
fourth quarter they proved that they
belong and it's going to be interesting
to see whether or not they can make
similar runs late in games if they
really are in a higher level of shape
than their opponents well yeah i think
that's their greatest advantage they
have right now that's the one thing i
took away from the game because i i
think the cardinals are the 31st best
team in football still i mean i don't
know if i would have ranked them there
you're right i'm just you got at the
right ranking but i still look at them
as certainly one of those bottom one or
two three teams that their great
advantage is a the point you just made
mike it really is they wore out the
lions and we know teams get worn out in
the fourth quarter as is anyways
defensive lines can get worn out from a
team that passes the ball too much but
when you're passing the ball every play
there's some moments of up tempo and
then you're chasing around to kyla
murray i mean this truly could be a
little bit of the formula
that cliff kingsbury is counting on to
to be implemented on a weekly basis hey
we're going to just wear you down with
we're in the shotgun it's this short
pass it's that short pass kyle murray
running around you got to chase him on
quarterback design movement plays let
alone the ones he scrambles and if you
don't have a deep defensive line uh and
a deep defense in general you could be
in trouble playing the arizona cardinals
i looked at that as their number one
advantage coming out of sunday
i love watching cardinals highlights i
love watching cardinals games and i know
that kyler murray isn't significantly
shorter than russell wilson or drew
brees but on a football field he looks
so tiny yes he does i don't know whether
it's because he's got short arms or what
it is he's a little more narrow right i
think he's a little more narrow shoulder
than like russell wilson too that way
it both fascinates me and horrifies me
because
you know i mean i'm at the age now where
some of these rookies are younger than
my son and it's you you'd be worried
about like i worry about kyler murray
but i also i love watching what he can
do and we'll see what he can do this
weekend against lamar jackson and the
baltimore raven
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports